here is the mission statement from
women's March calm the mission of
women's March is to harness the
political power of diverse women in
their communities to create
transformative social change women's
March is a women led movement providing
intersectional education on a diverse
range of issues and creating entry
points for new grassroots activists and
organizers to engage in their local
communities through trainings outreach
programs and events women's March is
committed to dismantling systems of
oppression through nonviolent resistance
and building inclusive structures guided
by self-determination dignity and
respect what what what what does any of
that mean they get a bit more as a
specific later on but this just shows
you how to out of touch they are the
first principle that they list is ending
violence they right women deserve to
live full and healthy lives free of all
forms of violence against our bodies
just to correct the record here women
live significantly longer than men on
average by the end of the 20th century
the u.s. male life expectancy was
seventy three point four years compared
to 80 point one years for women unlike
men when women register to vote they
don't simultaneously have to register
for the military draft men are far more
likely to be the victims of violent
crime than women seventy six point eight
percent of murder victims are male boys
and men are far more likely than girls
and women to be victims of assault and
robbery as well additionally according
to the Gallup World poll women report
being happier with their lives than
their male counterparts women's March
comm goes on to the euphemistically
titled reproductive rights they say we
believe in reproductive freedom we do
not accept any federal state or local
rollback cuts or restrictions on our
ability to access quality reproductive
health care services birth control
hiv/aids prevention or medically
accurate sexuality education this means
open access to safe legal affordable
abortion and birth control for all
people so it's all it's just about
abortion they put all that other stuff
there but it's really about abortion and
yet according to a 2016 Marist Poll
despite constant Democrat euphemisms
renaming abortion as women's issues or
reproductive health nationally
the vast majority of women 77 percent
support restricting abortion to at most
the first trimester far fewer just 71
percent of men support restrictions on
abortion the the women are clearer the
majority of women 59% say abortion is
morally wrong 52% of women believe that
abortion should at most at most be
permitted in cases of rape incest or to
save the life of the mother but
nevertheless according to the women's
March women want abortion on demand
anytime anyplace that just isn't backed
up by reality on workers rights women's
March com declares we believe in an
economy powered by transparency
accountability security and equity all
women should be paid equitably and you
hear this constantly this popular
disinformation that there's a gender pay
gap women make 77 cents on the dollar no
equal pay for equal work
but that gender pay gap disappears once
you control for factors like education
time in the industry and hours worked
actually single childless women in
metropolitan areas they don't earn less
than their male counterparts
they earn more than their male
counterparts by 8% on average nationally
women also graduate from college at
significantly higher rates than men in
2015 39% of women 25 to 29 had earned a
bachelor's degree compared to just 32
percent of men on civil rights women's
March com explains we believe civil
rights are our birthright including
voting rights this is odd to pick a
fight on voting rights as according to
the Center for American women and
politics since 1980 women have voted at
higher rates in every single
presidential election than men so by
2016
that gap widened to sixty three point
three percent of women voting compared
to just fifty nine point three percent
of men additionally the number of female
voters has exceeded the number of male
voters in every presidential election
since 1964
despite constituting a majority of the
US population 50.8% forty nine point two
percent women also benefit from
affirmative action policies on campus
and in the workplace that give them a
competitive advantage over men there's a
section on disability rights women's
March
comprar claims we believe that all
women's issues are issues faced by women
with disabilities and deaf women I guess
that one's right yes I guess that yes
that's very deaf women or still women I
don't know what the point of that is but
sure that is that's the one thing that
the women's March got right deaf women
are women on immigrant rights women's
marched out calm insists rooted in the
promise of America's call for huddled
masses yearning to breathe free we
believe in immigrant and refugee rights
regardless of status or country of
origin we believe migration is a human
right and that no human being is illegal
so putting aside for a moment the
illogic of a national policy to do away
with national borders even on the
numbers the women's march doesn't seem
to represent women even among illegal
aliens brought to the United States as
children and teenagers even the dreamers
the most sympathetic and relentlessly
demagogue group of illegal aliens a
November survey from morning consult and
Politico shows that fewer than 30
percent of Americans support amnesty
even among Democrats support for
granting amnesty to the most sympathetic
group of illegal aliens is just 44%
finally last segment on environmental
justice women's March comm observes we
believe that every person in every
community in our nation has the right to
clean water clean air and access to an
enjoyment of public lands lucky for them
federal law has protected all of those
things to say nothing of state and local
management for at least the past five
decades the women's March is the most
frivolous protest in the history of the
world